the five's outside on fox square for
veterans day paying tribute to all of
our heroic men and women who've served
we're going to be honoring veterans on
set later in the show but first the
united states of america is the greatest
country in the world a place where you
can do anything and you can be anything
a place where a better tomorrow is not
just a hope but a guarantee
but freedom isn't free and on veterans
day we must pay tribute to those
sacrificed so much
so we here at home don't have to
sacrifice at all
millions of brave men and women have
fought to protect our nation they come
from all different backgrounds and
creeds they put themselves in harm's way
without question without prejudice
without terms
knowing full well the dangers they face
may cost them their lives yet they
answer the call
they wear their uniforms proudly and put
country over self
they stand strongly to defend our flag
ensuring our liberties remain intact
our veterans who time and time again
find themselves in the midst of
impossible situations prove that
anything is possible
when things got bad in afghanistan it
was veterans groups that rallied
together to keep their sacred promise to
never leave anybody behind
they refused to give up and they got
people out when no one else would
our veterans show compassion during
chaos they prove that no act of kindness
is too small and exemplify what it truly
means to be selfless
the courage of our veterans cannot be
forgotten we must honor them we must
respect them we must thank them we must
always remember them because our
veterans are not just the best of
america
they are america
greg gutfeld your thoughts on veterans
day i thought that was a fantastic
monologue thank you um he's mr president
oh yeah can we do a side by side of me
and uh jesse for a minute here
why does he have all the flags my fellow
americans this is this is clearly this
is clear you this is deliberate you get
all the look i served and you did not
that's too by the way he's right
we're talking about all these uh the
veterans of all these wars we cannot
forget the war on christmas that's right
uh jesse waters was a selfless volunteer
and veteran fighting the war on
christmas while i was home drinking
eggnog you were out there preserving my
freedom to hang mistletoe in public
restrooms and we thank you yes but i
want to say this thank you because a lot
you know fox when fox talks about
veterans it's not lip service we
actually follow through with everything
and i think we've hired a lot of
veterans and so i mean it's advice to
employers that when you hire a veteran
you have like a
no you have zero risk of failure yeah
because when you when the vet arrives to
your place of work fully packaged like
all the ingredients are there it's like
when you buy one of those prepared meals
that has everything because so i wrote
down like veterans have the secrets to
life already solved
they have a uh they keep a routine that
begins early in the morning anybody who
does that succeeds they have impeccable
personal grooming i don't know one
sloppy veteran they have manners and
they have discipline which is on short
supply these days and they appreciate
hard work they're not scared of it so in
this era of like the tick tock
generation
it's hard to come by these qualities but
the veteran has it in spades that is a
great point i'm going to go hire a
veteran right now for water as well
you're not going to make them drive you
home that is disgusting
that veteran might whip you into shape i
need it especially on the grooming side
your parents would be so proud they
would your thoughts on this very special
day i was thinking about how this day
comes just before thanksgiving every
year and when you think when you go
around the table of thanksgiving what
are you thankful for um for all of us i
think
as americans that should be number one
right your health your family yes of
course your employment but the fact that
there are people in this country that
volunteer to defend us um and they go
there with no politics
and they go there with kindness
bravery courage
that that really is the meaning of
thanksgiving to me judge jeanine hi
how are you doing oh well we're working
on my hearing tonight okay well i listen
you know i have to tell you what greg
said really brought something to my mind
about hiring a veteran and that is you
know we talk about affirmative action
and there's been all this arguing about
you know we should have it we shouldn't
have it you know maybe we should have
affirmative action for veterans i don't
care what color they are i don't care
what nationality they are they're the
ones who put their lives on the line
they're the ones who've decided you know
that they come back with maybe one or
two limbs or three limbs less than fewer
than when they started and in fact i'm
sitting here now i'm wearing my dad's
pin from the navy
and it says obedience zeal and uh i
don't know what the third one is z oh
fidelity and it has his name on the back
it says nasser leo ferris 1945.
that's amazing and i remember when i was
a kid i used to wear his uniform and we
always had the american flag hanging in
front of our house and i still do to
this day
and my dad was on the first ship to
nakisaki in the navy and he saw the
plume and he died early as a result of
you know seeing the plume he had head
and neck cancer from it
but you know to this day both he and my
granddad fought in world war ii i
believe in veterans i believe in america
i am so hurt at what is happening today
when people don't recognize the
significance of these people who go
to our children our brothers our parents
our sisters and do this for america
jessica
i echo everyone's sentiments and adding
to greg's list team players
veterans know how to work in a team in
an increasingly isolated culture where
people are kind of
out for themselves or not thinking about
your neighbors or someone who you'd be
working with and the skills that
veterans need to be taught
when they go into employment in the
civilian world are no big deal you can
teach them to program you can teach them
to do whatever it is that you need the
stuff that they've learned before is far
more valuable and one thing that's
really nice about veterans day and just
in talking about the subject is it's
unifying across the political aisle
there was a new study out from yougov
that showed everybody over 70 says we
don't do enough for our veterans when
you think of what they suffer from
mental health crises the homelessness
crisis
making sure that they get great health
care that they deserve after serving um
it's nice to all be on the same side can
i mention one thing about the employment
there's a strange thing with uh veterans
or say your active duty military and
you're going to transition out
for some reason there's many of them
don't think that they have skills right
that could be useful in the private
sector so we're telling employers hire
veterans but we should also say to you
you do have the skills yep um just reach
out to one of these groups that can help
you figure out how basically if you
figure out how to prevent a bombing of a
major sensitive
unit then you can actually pretty much
do anything in the private sector so
just take heart and look forward to
great opportunities when you return if
you've bombed the unit send me the
resume
i want to talk to you
the five will continue to honor those
who served and we're going to introduce
you to some very great veterans later on
in the show hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else